I think the general principles of
philanthropy are that giving the money
is not what's important it's actually
what the money enables you to do and the
idea is that the money stimulates
development so what what we have to do
is we have to invest these resources in
in solutions to these very difficult
social problems that are first of all
that are implementable and scalable so
you know we don't want to create little
projects that are wildly successful but
they cost you know one hundred thousand
dollars per person benefited we've got
it we've got to find ways of doing
things that are scalable we've got to
find ways of doing things that can be
implemented and I also believe that that
that that the best philanthropy that
could be invested is philanthropy that
starts to work out and prove some of
these models of value that I was that I
was talking about so again when enough
for sources you can solve almost
anybody's problem you can give them all
the food they need you give them housing
you can give them you know how you can
you pay for the health care you can
provide free medicine you can but but
that's not sustainable yeah what you've
got to do is you've got to find ways of
equipping people with the skills and the
talent and the attitude the orientations
and the access to to you create their
own solutions to their own problem and
that that sometimes that means some some
different kind of investments so I worry
that i worry about philanthropist who
who are 22 caring and 22 focused on
really wanting to help people and
demonstrate that they've they've you
know they've they fed this many children
or they've they've they've provided this
many mosquito nets and and I think the
Gates Foundation i think is starting
to come into its own in terms of
understanding that its greatest
contribution is is about ideas it's not
the money it's the ideas it's it's
finding and validating so the
sustainable models that then they can
they can scale but others can't get can
join so I don't know if that answers
exactly your the question of how you
would give this kind of a vast resource
but it's it's certainly the answer that
that i would i would give i would also
say that there's a tremendous tennessee
and flan to be for example in health
care to give the money for the science
you know to fund that researcher who's
going to come up with that cure for
cancer but i think we equally we have to
understand that that that that some of
the most important problems of human
society are not so much about the
scientific where the technical or the
tools but they're about the application
and and so i guess i'd like to see more
i would put more if i had it of
resources into those areas